This guy account though has tweets like, "So, how long until
Destiny gets banned from this app? # DGG # Dalaban
# Destiny. Tankies are already terrified of arriving Daliban
forces following back all liberals # DGG." Now, the reason that
these posts are relevant is because Destiny is quite famous for
saying very unhinged, offensive.
guys, we we're finally here. This is like the big piece that
everybody was watching today and yesterday, and I haven't seen
it yet. I haven't seen any part of it, actually. So, I'm excited
to see. Apparently, Idubbbz is just the worst. So, I guess we'll
have to see.
He's just totally incapable of making any argument ever. I'm
not total I'm not sure. Oh, what's up, Viz? Welcome, welcome,
welcome. Hello.
I was ignoring this until now. Well, we're going to check it
out. Here it is.
Um, I actually don't have Has anyone Have either of you guys
seen anything about this? Oh, I guess Creator Clash stuff and
then concern. Okay, so it'll be in response to him and his wife
have been getting blown up by everybody. They're kind of getting
targeted by like everybody on social media right now. So, I'm
guessing this will be a response to Yeah. some of the stuff around
Creator Clash. I think one of the big allegations I saw was that
they were taking even from this Creator Clash like 20 or 25%
of profits, right?
Yeah. I've been seeing a lot of tweets going out about this.
I'm not totally informed.
Now, thankfully for me, I have the majority of this video already
recorded. This is just a little addendum. I think an addendum
is something that you put at the end, but this is a predendum.
I'm throwing in a little predendum. Something that I've been
struggling with for a long time on YouTube is concern trolling.
The thing that I really struggle with is not identifying concern
trolling. The difficult part of it is when there are people who
have authentic concern out there and the concerned trolls are
concerned over the same thing. So I'm like, "Oh, I'm giving in
to the concerned trolls by addressing, you know, this
population or this segment of 34%. Damn. 34% of the profits,
my fan base who have genuine concerns. So I don't want to let
the trolls inhibit my ability to communicate to my fans or people
who are confused out there. So, I want to talk about Creator
Clash. I want to talk about the structure of the business and
how it's changed over the years. And you guys are going to be
disappointed when you learn that that's the case for a lot of
charitable fundraising and for the charity structured themselves.
They have to pay people to work for them because very few people
want to do a significant or can even do a significant amount
of work for charity without being paid.
Uh I don't think anybody's shocked that they would take um payments.
I think people are shocked that they would take 34% of all profits.
Well, profits are after you've covered your expenses and everything
else, right? So, if the that is the definition of profits. Yes.
Yes. So, presumably well, I don't know how what the percentage
was for going to quotation charity and what what the rest was
the rest. I don't know either. I also don't know the order. If
it would be get them getting paid out to charity or something
and then they take profit after that, then maybe. Wait, did he
just confirm it or was that the rumor before this video happened?
I believe that was in a contract that people found. So, I think
he will address it at some point, I assume. Okay. As far as I
remember though, didn't they always call themselves a nonprofit
that was raising money for charitable causes, not a charity in
of itself. I could be wrong, but I thought that was the case
to start with. Do you remember the Cuz like last year they it
up. No, not last year, the last one they literally said that
they um only just covered their expenses and broke even or whatever,
so they didn't really have enough to like donate to charity,
so they did fundraising after the fact, wasn't it? That was Creator
Clash 2. Yeah. Yeah. They actually were significantly in the
red for that.
Yeah. Oh, so they didn't even cover their expenses. I thought
it was that they didn't have enough money left over to donate
anything to charity. I think they didn't donate anything to charity
and that was because they were still in the red significantly
from the event. So they was they were um they didn't even cover
their expenses as well. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Yep. Damn. I wonder
I don't know. So if it was a nonprofit versus a charity, like
what would be the difference there? Uh there is a difference.
Yeah. Nonprofit just means that you're not necessarily making
significant amounts of money from an event, but it's a bit of
a gray area. They say they're taking 34% of profits, but it depends
what you're doing with those 34% of the profits. If it's being
put back into the business,
uh whether that's classified. Again, you could probably just
look up what is Creator Clash listed as. And then it will give
you like a code and then you can see if it's a nonprofit or a
charitable organization or what it is. Does anyone know what
it is? I'm sure there's some legal definition for like a nonprofit
that they need to
meet in order to register for that. And yeah, you have to register.
I'm super shocked if the percentage that they give is like literally
like 1% lower than what they are allowed to take to qualify.
Yeah. Um,
if anybody has a minute to look that up, I would just check like
Nick Duru's tweets. You probably know whether or not it's a 501c3
like a I believe that would be a nonprofit. Yes, 501c3 or whether
it's like a charitable organization. Any of the lies that are
being spread out there about Ana, about me, and about the event.
My main incentive for sharing this information is that I h have
felt extremely handcuffed by Creator Clash these past years because
I'm not an expert communicator and I don't know how to convey
things, not overcommunicate,
uh, not do all these things that potentially put the event at
risk and put other people at risk. And that's kind of why I'm
I wanted to step away from this event. It feels like it's inhibiting
my ability like the business side of things like inhibits my
ability to communicate openly and effectively especially when
there's so many people counting on me to you know do that well.
So it's a lot of pressure and uh now that Ana and I have stepped
away from it I want to just clear the air because I don't feel
that same pressure that
uh we covered the the Trump stuff earlier atachi but unfortunately
for you buddy
uh we're going to shut the Twitch stream off go to kick only.
So guys, if you're watching on Twitch, we're going kick only
for the rest of the stream. Good luck. We love you guys over
on Twitch, but we're we're switching over to kickonly. Okay,
see you over there in a bit. I'll put the the link in the chat.
All right.
It seems like they were always just a pro forprofit event. Also
just raised money for charity as well, as far as I can tell.
Okay, cool, cool, cool, cool.
Give me a second here. I don't know what they're registered as.
I guess I have to look. Okay. when I was part of the event. If
you YouTube is still in the air, I will let you guys know. As
soon as I hear back from YouTube, I will let you guys know. Look
into charity events. They come in so many different shapes and
sizes and there is really no format that is completely obvious
for creator boxing plus charity. For the first creator clash,
we had the business model of after everyone has been paid for,
you know, the expenses of the event, all profits go to charity.
That was the business model and it was successful. Thankfully,
it worked out the first year. Now, some people will be critical
of one of the costs being parties for Creator Clash 2 and actually
Creator Clash one because that's where we got the idea from.
It was very successful for Creator Clash one or the event was
successful. We don't know if the party worked to encourage people
to promote the event, but that was the idea. You get a bunch
of creators to show up to a hotel the night before their fight
and they're going to post about it on social media and the internet
will be a buzz and well I thought there was like a postfight
party as well. The event was successful. So we thought that that
strategy of having you know a little hubbhub a little halaloo
before the event and after the event was a good idea. So, we
ran with that strategy again, hoping that creators will post
about it and be excited about it and buzz will be gen Hold on.
I didn't see this earlier, but apparently
apparently after much work by our best negotiators, I'm pleased
to announce a trade deal by the US and China. Both sides will
reduce tariffs significantly. China will buy large amounts of
American agriculture, pharmaceuticals, and financial products,
and American consumers will have access to the best EVs in the
world from BYYD, Sherry, and NIO among others. Win-win. Smart
move by my good friend she dude. He did he sign a trade agreement
just to Elon Musk over? Did he actually do that? Did he actually
just Wait, hold on. Cuz unironically they do have better EVs.
I know. Well, they're cheap as I've heard that and that they're
prevented from being in the American market. But I feel like
I feel like this would have been China a big sticking point for
China and Trump would have just gone you know what Elon Musk
I think he actually did that.
I'm going to be real. Is is Trump not doing it again?
Doing what again? Isn't this what he did last time? It looks
like he's shaking hands with like some of the most corrupt people.
Like Elon Musk is the definition of like a greedy capitalist.
Way too much power. I think he was trying to get his hands in
the EU to
uh rake for himself.
And
yeah, I I feel like Trump just uh broke that up a bit, right?
Unfortunately, to help China out. Are you lost?
Yeah, break that [__] up a bit. I Sorry. Yeah, I
think it was just to Elon Musk. I think it was explicitly like
he didn't want these things here. He wanted to promote American.
Okay, go. But we're looking we're looking at Elon as if like
he's a huge victim, but Elon went into it with the intention
of creating an even bigger monopoly for himself, right? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. And you're like he's kind of takes advantage you
think he kind of takes advantage of those people and then he
uses them and throws them away. It just it always seems like
uh
there's the concern that you know Trump isn't draining the swamp.
He's just working with all these corrupt people. But then you
give it like a year or two and all those people tend to fall
on their ass.
Yeah. That's what happened with the politicians in 2016.
He's been um
he's just been like a charlatan longer than them. Okay. He's
just better at it. He knows He knows he can take advantage of
the other charlatans. Okay,
that's that is funny. Yeah, I guess I I don't know which politicians
got and I think basically as long as you keep it's like if you
have an ego and you're also a charlatan, you'll get destroyed.
Get [__] again. Like all of the old heads in the
Republican party came on board with him, right? And they all
got subpoenenaed or convicted one by one.
Well, a lot of them did. I think as long as you're if you don't
have an ego, I think you're fine. Like even Yeah. Yeah. I think
if you don't have an ego, you're fine. But if you want the spotlight,
you want to be like the people person people praise like Elon
did or like any of the there's a bunch of other people like Rance
Priebus, a whole bunch of people who Yeah. one also had egos
and they just got destroyed like one by one.
Yeah. I think this just it feels like he's like Trump I don't
think by any effort like on his part, right? He's unintentionally
actually doing it. He's getting Well, I mean I Yeah, I think
I don't I don't know how much he got people before, but I think
he is un he's unironically doing it because maybe Elon Musk might
be the biggest risk to democracy in the world. Yes. How does
somebody say doing what? Literally the idea that Elon Musk would
go into
uh into work the government to try to uh fix the budget or fix
the the deficit and the spending knowing how much money he has.
Richest man in the world and he takes government subsidies. Weren't
we all laughing at this? Yeah. And he come over. That's what
you're talking about. Sorry, I'm trying to say it. Maybe the
chatter needs to hear a male voice say
An authoritative male voice. I'll just I'll say okay. Are we
still going to wait for that then?
Kelly's always on the ball.
Now, thankfully for me, I have the majority of this video already
record. What's that?
Stop bringing up ball or I am going to make fun of you for the
yoga ball. This is just a little dangling that in front of my
face.
I'm going to say on the ball and yeah, you can just make your
jokes cuz you you really have to imagery.
I think an addendum is something that you put at the end, but
this is a predendum. I'm throwing in a little pre Oh, did this
restart? Oh, no. I had this open before, didn't I? Yeah, I did.
Generated, but it didn't happen. Or maybe it So, he's saying
you have to have a party beforehand to make sure you get hyped
for the event and people are there. Did happen, but it just didn't
sell tickets. I would cross that off my list as a learning experience
of well, if you do this strategy, you either got to force people
to post about it or you have to um I don't know, not do it. You
got to you got to make sure that people are slapping each other
during the weigh-in. That's probably what I'd change it to cuz
it's cheaper. You know, it's a lot cheaper if people slap each
other during the weigh-in. I just wasn't about that. I was just
like, I don't want this fake drama [__] For the second
creator clash, we used the same business model. This time, we
increased the budget. We had more fighters, we had a bigger arena
and more expenses in general. As a result of that, uh there were
a lot more costs and our ticket sales did not make up those costs.
It seemed very obvious that this was not the way to run the charity
boxing event. We told our business partners, we are not going
to do this event again unless it can be promised to us that there
was a way to guarantee money for charity. And the business model
that was presented to us was what we're enacting or what we did
enact this year with Creator Clash 3. And that is okay. So basically
that means that probably whatever profits they're taking, they
probably only take those profits after the charities have been
paid out, right? That has to be what that means. There's there's
no possible way. You're under the impression that Ian is the
most felted man in the world right now. Uh he is, but I'm trying
to figure out what the truth is here. Obviously. Obviously. the
forprofit side. Do you want me to just like I I just don't see
any point in sitting here like um like seal clapping along and
going like, "Yeah, he's so bad." I I just don't I'm like just
going to watch it, right? I'm just going to watch the video and
react to the video.
I've not been avoiding watching it. I just Yeah, I've not been
avoiding watching it at all. I'm just going to actually listen.
This is unincorporated
with the charity aspect. So, the charity partner is Okay, alien
mode. But I'm going to help you out here. You can uh take an
hour off, 2 hours off, and then you don't have to watch. Good
luck. Is it fun that we sort of like put people to, you know,
before, during, and after the event? I think where some of the
confusion is is that many people don't understand how charity
events operate because to be honest, they're all very different.
And with something like a charity boxing event, there's a lot
of money that you have to front to put it on in the first place.
And if you have a like an investor, you're able to do that. That
investor is going to want money. They're going to want profit,
but that at least gives you the initial funds to put on the event.
There are other charity initiatives and events that allow people
to uh spend money for a ticket and immediately get a product
and also their money goes to charity. Those are usually big conglomerates,
giant companies that can afford that cost because they're selling
you other things. Some people have an idea of charity events
as being like a a strictly altruistic thing where everyone is
just sacrificing their time and energy and money for the charity.
To put on a boxing event costs a lot of money. And uh even in
other examples like GDQ, Games DoneQuick is a a charity uh event,
but they're not like a charity themselves. You know, they run
a business and they partner with a charity and they fund raise
for the charity. They send people to the charity and thankfully
they have, you know, multiple ways of of being paid and paying
the people who are running the show. That might be through payment
from the charity. that might be through their own like Twitch
stream or merchandise. I just know that for a charity boxing
event in the form of creator clash, there aren't too many ways
to recoup your money other than ticket sales. And that was obviously
the biggest challenge of the previous two events. When it does
well, awesome. But when it doesn't, it's a huge problem. It remains
to be seen whether the for-profit business side of the event
will be successful. But the main controversy I would say is that
it was revealed with the change of ownership that Anise and I
because we're one-third ownership of Creator Clash the business
that we were getting 34.
Are you covering the H3 plus Ian's coat content? Probably not.
Uh I just going to review this video to see like what he's saying
in response to some of these things. Um anyway, also guys, if
you like the content, how long do we have on the stream right
now? An hour and a half. Hour and 30 minutes, guys. If you want
more time on the stream, there's a couple ways that you can get
more times on time on the stream. Okay. Wait. Oh, sorry. Yeah.
Do your pitch.
Okay. Um,
yeah, you can sub on kick, you can sub on Twitch, you can donate
through either of the donation links. Exclamation point. Donate
in the chat. Okay. Either donation link goes through. You can
add more time to the stream through any of those methods. We
are five subs away from another hour on the stream. Okay. And
guys, last but not least is Patreon.
Um, I wouldn't be shocked if people want to wait until we start
doing more content for the older stuff, but if you would like
to sub in a way that helps exclusively and doesn't add time to
the stream, okay? Doesn't add time to the stream, they're at
the Patreon. Uh, I appreciate every dollar that comes in through
this because it's uh, you know, it's super helpful, super appreciated.
Um, lots of different Discord perks for the different roles.
Okay. Uh, every role that is available to you will get you voice
uh, sorry, not voice, soundboards in the Discord channels. It
will get you priority access to Cullins if we start doing that
again. We haven't been doing it recently, but um I'm sure there
will be nights where I'm like alone. I just I'm looking for people
to talk to. Okay, so priority access to that. Um what else is
there for Oiler calls? There's the pre-stream, postream content,
okay? Or in the oiler tier. And then the JWDP tier, you get to
pick your own color in the Discord. I think you get to edit messages
or delete messages in the general chat as well. So guys, massive
massive perks, okay? Like your own messages, right? Not No, you
get to delete everybody's messages technically. And if anybody
if we ever get people who sign up enough for this tier
um and they're abusing it, then maybe we'll change that. But
right now, they don't abuse it. So awesome. Amazing. Yeah. Very
based. Very cool. All right,
continuing on with the stream.
Let's go back to the video. Oneird of former one-third owners
and they get a one-third profit share. Oh, Marty Epste with 10
gifted. Let's go. So this says the fighters, right? Do the fighters
get paid? They get a further 34% of the profit share.
That actually doesn't make sense, right? Because if it's out
of the profits, then it's not a tax writeoff,
but it would be a tax write off if you pay the volunteers. The
fighters are volunteers. I don't understand this. Uh I don't
necessarily understand. It goes to the prize pool for what? I
assume there's a prize pool of the fighters or some whoever wins.
I don't know. Well, do the fighters get paid? Yes. Each fighter
receives a gu I think this is a guaranteed stipend, but I don't
know why there's 20% of net. Oh, yeah. For like the training
and the whatever. Yeah. I don't even know what the rest of this
line is
necessarily.
Oh, maybe just everything that's raised is considered profit
share. I don't know.
Well, I think I think basically after the event like the hard
like the rent costs and stuff then I think and I think the fighters
get like a guaranteed like built-in amount of money to train
and then from there I think it's profits. Yeah. So there's the
guarantee. One says net profit, one says profit share. So what's
the difference between those?
I think they would be the same thing and like they're the same
a further 34. So it's literally same profits too. They can't
be the same. They have to be different. Why?
Because one says net profits and then say the other says profit
shares a further 34% profit share. So this is like a share in
addition 20% of net profits go to somebody. 20% of net profits
that is a profit share. They just don't have it written there.
Right. You're sharing net profits with somebody.
I assume it's the fighters and then a further 34%. No, this is
all for the fighters because it says at the top, do the fighters
get paid? And then there's three bullet points on how they get
paid. I'll just look it up because I we he for some reason didn't
include the whole thing. Transparency.
Do the fighters get paid? Yes. Each fighter receives a guaranteed
purse to help cover training and preparation expenses. In addition,
20% of net profits from the event will be eventually evenly split
among all fighters. A further 34% profit share originally allocated
to Ian and Ana is also being redistributed among the followup
fighters following their departure. So I'm guessing that's what
they're complaining about. Yeah, this is what they're complaining
about. Yeah, it was they're complaining about that they used
to get this 34%.
Yeah, they're legit. They're just two different things. I looked
it up. No, no. It like it was in the contract. And I guess once
they realize that it's a bad look, they're like, "No, no, no.
This this is going to go to the fighters now.
That it was always like this and then they just backed out completely
from the event. So, they haven't just given that percentage.
They've removed themselves from the event completely. So obviously
now that profit share is left over.
Yes.
Oh, okay. But people are mad because they had a 34% profit share.
Yeah. Profit share, I looked it up, is like an pre-agreed on
thing.
It's not the same as net profit, but it's calculated from the
net profit. Yes. So if you calculate 20% of the net profits,
what would we call that? Sorry, what? It's 20% of the net profits.
She's saying that the profit share is from the net profit, but
it's just calculated
uh differently
out of the net profit. Yeah, it's it's um it's it's a predefined
So, it's not it's like something that's agreed on beforehand.
Net profit is obviously just the profit you have after you've
taken your expenses out. And then I think profit share would
be calculated according to how many people are part of the contract.
Yeah, it's the same like other employees and shareholders and
stuff. Yeah. Okay. I the to me they're the same thing and nothing
said here changes my mind on that. But I don't really think anywhere
arguing. No, it's like median and mean, right? There's just different
calculations. So the number is going to end up differently.
A further 34%.
Why would it be a further 34%. Can I just ask why it would be
a further 34% if it's not also being calculated from the net
profit? Because there there's like let's say that there's $100,
right?
Some of that $100 is going to be uh
just allocated by the fact that it's the $100 that's the net
profit, right? You're going to get 20% of this. But then there
are other people who are going to take like the last portions
and they're going to distribute it according to like how many
people are involved in the contract. It makes perfect sense.
What don't you get? I something I'm missing something entirely.
I feel like I just explained what the definition of it was. Then
you said it's the same. I was like, well, no,
it can't be the same if it requires profit%
profit share. Yeah, it wouldn't it wouldn't be 54% because these
are different numbers, is what they're saying. Exactly. Yeah,
but I would argue it's 54% of the net profits are going to the
fighters now. That is what I think this says
would be 54% that okay. Okay. I I'm I'm just missing something
and I probably am going to be a So
um we should continue. Yeah, I don't know what I don't understand
here. Um
if one of the other people understands then if somebody in chat
like understands and can explain it. Marty Epste. What did Marty
Epstein say? Shareholders in a nonprofit. I don't know. I'm going
to I don't think it's a nonprofit necessarily. I don't understand,
but I do understand that that it should absolutely be different
numbers.
Okay. All right.
Uh yeah, we of the profit share. We weren't anticipating this
event doing well like we wanted to do well enough to pay back
the investors of course. So that's one of the reasons that we
were, you know, okay with the profit share thing. But another
part of it as well is that the contract wasn't structured in
a way that uh
it's not 54% because 34 okay because the 34% goes out first or
comes after the 20% is already taken. Okay.
All right.
So then I kind of cost deducted. Net is always after I net is
always after costs are deducted. Yeah. I thought cuz I'm going
to be real. I was just guessing. Uh trying to use context clues.
I felt like I had to be a little bit humble at the end. Yeah.
Anyway,
net is after all costs and expenses. Okay. So, if that's the
definition of net, then why uh you know what? I actually don't
care and don't want to know. I'm just going to hit play. The
profit share could say go to charity. It was told to us. If she
told you they were two different definitions and you ignored
me. Mhm. There to charity after the event. So, we were like,
"Okay, fine." Now, I know I was actually 100% correct. I know
I'm 100% correct. I would bet money would anybody here
just
100 bucks one to one right now that I'm correct. 100 bucks one
right now. How How in the are you so exhausted from
that they are different? He was so exhausted. He's ready to just
start the video again. And then Kelly had to remind him, well,
I understood.
And that's when he's okay. Well, I know it was correct. Just
take it all back. I So, one of you wants to bet me $100 on this.
Yeah, I will bet you. Okay, it we you don't know the model that
they're using for profit.
He doesn't know anything. He just knows if he says, "Oh, I'll
bet you money." That I know English. Usually, usually nobody
gives a to bet money with it, right? Cuz he's using Kelly, you're
willing to bet too, right? Kelly, you're willing to bet. I'll
bet. No,
I told you that there are two different definitions of words.
I will throw down another hundred for Kelly. I got share. You
got because profit share is often taken from the net profit.
You need the net profit to calculate a profit share. And then
that's I got 200 on Kelly.
You're saying it exactly right, Kelly. You're saying it exactly
right. If I were to take 20% out of the net profit after we've
calculated the net profit and I took 20% out of that, what would
I call that? You It might not necessarily be that because we
don't know the model that they're using.
Okay, that's what I just said. The first thing I accept both
bets, Sherry. Thank you. Some people will find it hard to believe
that Anise and I were just going to give our portion of the profit
share to charity. There's nothing I could really say to I think
convince them otherwise. It was up to our discretion at the end
of the day. And this is 100%
100% what I am saying. Unite profit share is derived from the
net profit. The company first calculates its net profit and then
based on the predetermined formula plan allocates a portion of
that net profit as profit share. Yep.
Profit share. And you would calculate the profit share from that
net profit. Okay. Hey, which is why which is why they explicitly
which is why they explicitly say a further 34% profit share as
in this is a profit share and a further 34% profit share will
be no it could be for example it could be based on like gross
profit. So they p the person that's getting 20% would get 20%
of net profit and then the other person could get 34% of gross
profit and then that calculation would be different.
But I thought you said a profit share is calculated from net
profit. Kelly it's no I quite clearly said usually not is oh
okay or can be clearly usually plus a further different numbers.
Are you sorry do you think you're betting me that 20 and 34 are
two different numbers? know that net profits and profit share
are two different
Sure. But this is not net profit as a number. It's 20% of net
profits.
Yeah. So 20% of net profits.
Net profits is a different number from profit share. The fact
that you think you would just combine 20 and 34
as if these numbers are coming from the same place.
You lost. calculated. They calculate the net profit. You lost
before I even understood what either of those numbers are going
to be. You're wrong. It's fine. They calculate the net profit.
20% of that net profit goes to some people. 34% goes to Idubbbz
and Ana. Now, instead of that, 54% of that net profit will go
to the fighters split evenly among the fighters. No.
100%. But it's fine. We can now move on cuz I You said it was
going to be 54 and you are wrong. Okay. If it's not 54% of net
profits being split amongst fighters, then I am wrong. And I
can't know the answer to any of this because none of us know
what their agreement is. So, it's all like speculation. You're
arguing over something very stupid. We don't know.
Okay. God,
depends on what they decided they're doing. We don't know, do
we?
I They are saying explicitly here. I'm I'm No, they're not. You
don't know the details of their agreement. You don't know if
the 20% of net profits is coming out first and then the 34% is
of gross profit or or of the net profit that is left. You don't
know because we don't know the terms.
Uh again, there's no reason. So when you write English,
a further 34% profit share is saying there was a previous
you being a condescending prick and this isn't an agreement.
We're not looking at a contract. We're looking at two sentences.
Okay. this 34 I'll find the contract
something. Yeah. Yeah. So contract sounds like to you good.
It sounds like this 34% profit share that was going to be going
to Ian and Ana,
you know, for their involvement in this in the contract that
that's no longer happening. So now they're adding that to the
bottom of this list of things that the fighters are going to
get. Almost like that was something that was supposed to come
out before the net profits. So it kind of sounds like that profit
share is a number that was agreed upon before, you know, seeing
if they were going to earn anything. Okay. You know what? You
want to go find stuff out? Just you. I'm done.
Okay. This is dumb. And if you don't believe us, I can't say
anything because this mother loves arguing with people, loves
debating people, but the only way that he actually knows how
to debate people is by doing like this. I'm not trying to like
he should give us a hundred bucks each just for wasting our time.
He will. My only appeal is that year one we made a bunch of money
for charity and I just got the fighters pay like everyone else.
In year two of the event, we definitely got nothing. So yeah,
having said all of this, I know that there's probably a lot of
you out there who honestly don't care and you're just like, you
want to see boxing or you just want to see regular videos. I
get that for my soul. I needed to communicate it. So yeah, that's
a big relief for me. I mean, I'm very happy that uh you know,
this year money is being raised for charity and um I'm glad to
know that um it's already more successful than than year two.
Mission accomplished as far as I'm concerned.
Wow. I responded to his personal attack with a joke and then
he hit me with a concern troll from the right. There's a lot
of concern trolling around small businesses. This is the most
boring kind of concern troll. Get Snoop Dogg and Tupac the concern
troll. Concern trolling. You need to address this issue, man,
because you are offending the trans community. Shut up. That
is such poor concern trolling. Lindsey Graham did a lot of concern
trolling about this. His concern trolling is empirically
wrong. Oh, dude. This is like the hardest concern trolling I've
ever heard in my entire life. Dude, you don't answer to the concern
trolls. Concern trolling about homeless people. This guy's an
example of a concern troll. Concern trolling about fairness.
They sit on the sidelines and they concern troll. It's basically
concern
Why? Why? What is this serving? That you're going to show other
people talk about concern trolling. If a lot of people do concern
trolls, concern trolling. That's That's not Wait, that's not
It's basically concern trolling. If a lot of people
Is that contra points? That's contra points, isn't it?
In like the oldest setup. Oh jeez. Concern trolling. Concern
trolling. That's concern trolling. Concern trolls. Concern troll.
Concern trolling. Concern trolling. Concern trolling. Quintessential
concern troll. That was some expert concern trolling. Yes.
That dude's dead. Wait.
Oh, this guy. Yeah, I was like, Matt Bender is not dead. I see.
I've been working on my laugh lately. I'm trying to get it to
a level uh where it's
I haven't figured it out. I'll let you guys know when I figure
it out. Hello everyone. Welcome back to most human intro to a
segment. Guys, I've been working on my laugh recently.
Do you think it sounds human? Do you think it is contagious?
for another episode of Idubbbz Complaints. In the last couple
of videos, I got a lot of comments. Now, I don't have time to
read all 150,000 comments, but I also don't want to let down
my audience. You know, I want them to know that I hear you. I
hear your concerns and I'm listening. I've put all 150,000 comments
into the AI and I told it to condense it down into a singular
comment that is representative of the whole. My hope is that
the one comment will perfectly represent a small fragment of
everyone in the audience so everyone is equally happy. Okay.
Okay. Hold on a sec. So, I'm kind of lost. Who's Hassan again?
But hey, it's cool to see a content cop after all these years.
Still, I got to say something feels different, man. Did we lose
the plot somewhere? I miss the old days. But whatever. Keep doing
you, I guess. Anyway, peace out. I'm gonna go rewatch some Filthy
Frank. Now,
I'm gonna be honest. I'm a big fan of the one comment because
I I feel like it perfectly encapsulates a comment from like a
like a normie viewer who maybe watched you 5 years ago, but you
know, they don't keep up with the drama or anything. When I first
started my research on concern trolling, I was trying to find
scholars on the topic. I know it's not it hasn't been around
for that long, but I'm like surely there's someone who is well-versed
in the art of the troll. He's mastered that art of trolling.
To my surprise, the scholar on this topic is Anita Sarkeesian.
Yeah, it's been almost a decade since like the Gamergate time.
And go figure, the white guy 8 years later is like I think Anita
Sarkeesian was kind of on to something. There's a lot of on the
internet and they're kind of misogynistic too. I think it's crazy
what a little CTE or the love of a woman will do to you. Unfortunately,
that's not the only species of concern troll out there. The most
obvious definition for concern trolling is when someone is pretending
to be concerned about a particular subject or cause when in reality
they don't give a. They're just doing it to either get attention,
start a fight, derail the conversation. To be honest, it's very
effective cuz back in the day, you could identify someone trolling
pretty easily and you can kind of scroll past it. They'd have
a name like
and they would say fake and gay. But nowadays, it feels like
the average troll is going to give you a paragraph or two and
you will not be able to identify straight away if yes, that is
the entire thing. Yes, that concern trolling is bad and that
he's had to deal with it a lot. I see someone is with you or
not. Do they hate me? Is this are they making a point here? Should
I re
is that what it actually is or is it just You know what's concern
trolling, Kelly? When you wait 5 seconds after making your previous
statement to speak so that you wait and then I like hit play
and then you you start talking one full second after I hit play.
That's what me off, Kelly. Okay, that's what actually annoys
me. So concern trolling is whatever annoys you personally
in real life actually find you, Kelly. I will and do what? fatty
think my behavior. What the? It seems like they'll often times
give you their fan resume to like prove that they're not just
some random hater, right? They're not a troll or hater. They're
a fan who's been who's been supporting you since the Kickstarter
crap era. They've been supporting you since uh you made a NFT
of your ball sack. I've been subscribed since the Overgrowth
Let's Plays. Hello everybody and welcome back to more Overgrowth.
Just want to say that this video really missed the mark. Hope
that you can do better.
Hope that you can do better is such a great thing to say. It's
like you're a piece of Part of the reason I want to share this
is cuz I know there are a lot of creators out there who have
to deal with this on a regular basis. They have to be the ones
to differentiate between authentic and inauthentic. And a lot
of the time you just got to flip a coin or just ignore it outright.
And and it's really easy to say like I would handle that really
well because my policy is to not give a [__] about
any of it. But obviously if you do want to have some sort of
relationship with your audience or the internet in general, you
do have to give some percentage of attention to what's being
said online. That's going to be different for everyone. Now,
some people might be worried that I'm giving new strategies to
all the trolls out there, but don't worry, they already know
these strategies. This is kind of like a I think this is in all
of us, right? Like if you want some attention, you're going to
figure out a way to get the attention. If you want to with people,
you'll figure out how to with people. This isn't like some secret
sauce really. There's a few different strategies of dealing with
concerned trolls. You can obviously, you know, try to look into
their post history and if they don't come across as credible,
if all their post history is wiped, then you can just say, "I'm
going to heir on the side of you're trolling me." When I listen
to Tim P, he has like a little bit of a theory on, you know,
the left versus right and who is doing more concern trolling.
The right has their concern trolls, but it's rare. It rarely
happens. On the left, it's endless because people like Patton
Oswalt don't care about their about principle. Now, I don't fully
buy into what Tim P is selling here. You can kind of look at
the political spectrum as like a spectrum of concern. And people
on the left seem to be generally more concerned than people on
the right. You can say that people on the right are mostly concerned
about themselves. That might be like a fair uh assessment. If
you're somewhere over here where Tim Pool's at, all you got to
do to concern troll him is take one step to the left. That's
it. I think concern trolling is in the eye of the beholder. With
this example, you have Tim Pool thinking that uh Patton Oswald
is being concerned by his audience or a a portion maybe like
a small segment of of people. This is what happens when you fall
for this stuff. Patton Oswald falls for it. He is a weak weak
man. But Patton Oswald doesn't feel that way. You know, he sees
it as authentic concern, which is why he addresses it in this
Instagram post. By the way, the concern is basically just people
were uncomfortable with his association with Dave Chappelle because
Dave Chappelle did some transphobic or said some transphobic
[__] But Tim P has such a low emotional IQ that he
doesn't realize it. It isn't a big deal to listen to what other
people are saying and like adjust your behavior. It It's all
up to our own discretion, right? Like if you aren't to the point,
Tim, where you know you don't want to apologize for anything,
which by the way, it seems like that's a theme on your on your
podcast is basically saying like, I'm not a problem, but acting
like that's the the way the rest of the world needs to operate.
It's like I think Patton Oswald is doing just fine operating
the way he's operating. Wallow in it. Okay, Pad Oswalt, never
tell an offensive joke again. Never cross the line again. Good
luck trying to figure out where that line is. Good luck. You
won't find it. You give in to the concern trolls and you will
never work again. It's so funny, too, because Patton Oswald has
been doing comedy since Tim P was in diapers. What the are we
talking about? Can we please like I don't know. I It feels like
people like Tim Pool love to appeal to like authority all the
time. In this scenario, can we please appeal to authority or
acknowledge that this guy has tremendous authority over you in
the world of comedy? Unless you think comedy is saying like,
I went to a a bakery the other day. They had bagels. Really good.
Really good. Really impressed with it. That's the comedy you're
headed for. That's the joke South Park made. And even South Park,
I started pulling it to punches. Let me tell you about the real
world, my friends. Get woke, go broke. One of the reasons that
I'm bringing this up is because after the content cop, I noticed
a huge influx of concern trolls. They're trying to uh impact
things in the real world. They're trying to, you know, make people
crash out as I was kind of indicating in my video. But I will
say one of the concerned trolls was super obvious to me. They
came into the Discord. I I'll read you what they put so you can
kind of get a vibe for what a concerned troll might sound like.
Now, this comment is in reference to me saying that I think he
needs a good ass whooping. What are we saying? He needs a hug.
No, he doesn't need a hug. He needs a good ass whooping is what
he needs. They say, "Just being for real, this line in the video
was pretty strange." Red flag number one. At worst, it's a call
for physical assault. At best, it's very toxic masculinityesque.
It just comes across as parody, right? This was literally no
one's concern ever. He needs a good ass whooping is what he needs.
Either way, it doesn't seem to align with Ian's mentality towards
being more progressive and against harassment. You see what I
mean? It's trying to like insert like a little seed of doubt.
Whoa, you you might have been irresponsible here. You might need
to take accountability for what you've put out on the internet.
Never mind the point that you were making in the video. I think
you need to repent for your call to violence.
I don't think any creator should make that kind of statement
unless they have a very good reason to do so. morally speaking,
because you never know what one of your fans might do. It's quite
dangerous. I mean, to someone who hasn't been through the ringer
of concern trolling, I'm sure this could like upset or confuse
someone, but this is just dril. I honest to God just think his
vid and the whole intention would have been better without that
in it. I don't see why he said that. Gh. Of course, this is a
new user to our Discord, so no post history. So, we got to get
creative. You reverse search the username and you find that they
have a Twitter. Their Twitter is suspended. The Blue Sky account
though has tweets like, "So, how long until Destiny gets banned
from this app?
# Dalaban # Destiny Tankies are already terrified of arriving
Daliban forces following back all liberals. # DGG." Now, the
reason that these posts are relevant is because Destiny is quite
famous for saying very unhinged, offensive, and he doesn't really
seem to care that much about it. Don't pretend like you care
about mental health or any of that cringe. Just be based. Tell
people to kill themselves. Make fun of people who are on SSRIs.
Make fun of people who have depression or anxiety or GD. Just
do that. Just be just embrace the the I can't say the words on
stream anymore. The all the slurs and everything used to just
do that. Go full in on it. Now, I'm going to go out on a limb
here and say that I don't think this user is actually worried
about the language I'm using. I don't think that they're concerned
about me being toxic
Make fun of people who are on SSRI. And I kind of don't think
that they're worried about a call to violence. I actually think
that they wouldn't mind me doing a call to violence. Tell people
to kill themselves. They actually might even be encouraged by
a cult of violence if I had to guess. You know, I can only speculate
based on # Taliban, which is just some racist Twitter group.
Ultimately, concern trolling is just saying something in bad
faith. It's very similar to tone policing or sea lioning. But
I didn't really want to talk about those because those feel different
to me for some reason. Specifically, sea lioning. That isn't
even intuitive. You know, I've looked it up, I think, three times
now.
Uh, Zul, I don't care. I don't care about anything Idubbbz is
saying, to be honest with you. I don't know why I started watching
that video. I literally don't give a about anything Idubbbz has
to say.
Whoa, that was boring. Okay, I'm going to move on to something
else. What do we got here? Bob Lazar, Aliens. I got this clip
from Space Ghost, I think. And I wanted to check this out to
see if something had changed here.
I'm sorry. I'm just I literally am not listening. I don't care.
So, all right,
let's watch Nennessy and Papa Gut. Oh, we could maybe do that
later. Uh, we'll see. Maybe do that later. You go over the Bob
Lazar story. Like, what what do you how much of you how much
of you cries? How much of you is like h
more on the wh side? I think he's the most credible whistleblower
because he he didn't profit from didn't profit and they I mean
they prosecuted him for run for running a prostitution ring,
you know, which maybe he was, which I think he was. I he pled
down to pandering, but he they also raided him during the Jeremy
Corbel documentary while they're filming the documentary. I I
can't do that twisted rope. I've got no idea what you're talking
about. The FBI raided his facility. Mhm. And they said they were
looking for something. And supposedly he has a version or a a
sample of stable element 115. What? That's supposedly
Yeah. And that's supposedly what they were looking for. Supposedly
he had gotten that from the lab and when when he was at S4 and
that he had managed to smuggle out a a stable
chunk of this element 115. And there was a video that George
Knap had from back in the 80s where Lazar was demonstrating how
this stuff bends light and you know what it does like it has
weird effects. How soon after that raid was 115 is now called
Moscow. How soon after that raid was 115 synthesized? I think
synthesized in Russia would be well synthesized by a particle
collider and so the the when they got it is a very temporary
quickly dissolving form but they proved its existence
and supposedly what Lazar is saying wherever these beings are
from they obviously is this even completely different environment
and they have a stable says the footage that wasn't supposed
to be released is this the ship element yep and this element
is crucial to this gravity propulsion system. His facility and
oring for something and supposedly he has a version or a a sample
of stable element 15
is a very temporary
dissolving form but they prove it existence. I need like something
to like wake supposedly what Lazar is saying, wherever these
beings are from, they obviously have a completely different environment
and they have a stable version of this. Is there any Nick Ammo
content? I actually have no idea what's happened with them the
last week. I'm going to be honest. I don't know if there's anything
like interesting going on. They had one where ammo shut the Wi-Fi
off and Nick stream ended in a pretty funny way, but I think
that's about it. Oh, that's so funny. They're both so psychotic.
is crucial to this gravity propulsion system. Seriously, I just
how could you not feel like singles better than that? Gravity
field allows you to just slingshot through the the universe.
I I don't know. The worst you have to do is you know. All right.
I guess we're not going to pause the video today, are we? Ph.
Like the worst you'd have to accept is, oh, I guess I won't get
the absolutely
sanctuary in the middle of nowhere that I wanted, but like surely
you could just downgrade to having like a normalsized one. I
don't
slurring words. Shut up. I'm just tired, [__] I don't
know. Oh, Tree did join the Discord, but I don't know.
She has not joined the thingy. Okay. I don't know what's going
on.
Why would they raid Bob Lazar? That's so that's a spectrum of
believability again. Exactly. Here's a guy who's being attacked
and tormented in the middle of filming the documentary. You know
the the Nixon story with Jackie Gleason. Uh I know that Gleon
was into UFOs. Tell the story. The story is Gleason got into
UFOs because him and Nixon were drinking one day and Nixon was
like, "You want to see some? I wish I was drinking that."
And then he takes him, he flies him out to wherever the base
is and shows him a crashed UFO and these bodies that they have
in freezers. And it was Ry Patterson. I do not know. I do not
know. I don't know if Jackie Gleason ever said the story came
from Gleason's wife and it was an article in some sort of a magazine.
But then there's the house that Gleon built in upstate New York
that looked like a UFO. Like Gleon built a home.
Yeah. That was like like a disc. I'm going to look into this.
It's such a good story. I wonder where they went. Reportedly
would have been in Homestead Air Force Base. It might be in Florida
in 73.
I think that's where they were when they when they were playing
golf and bombed was reportedly showing embalmed bodies of four
alien beings. No, this is uh so
Nixon exposes UFOs to
for in the context for this footage. I have no idea. I'm like
not
so Nixon exposes the UFOs to a civilian and then it does not
go well for Richard Nixon after that. Well, I think what badly
for Richard five conspiracy theories
smooshed into one. What is this? Oh, I see. Is it just
the reason uh the person wanted me to look at it is basically
like this is 2 million views videos views in four days and it
actually makes no good.
can it doesn't make like a single good point
killed JFK the stuff they're talking about is actually legit
like okay legit in what way they already you know brought in
Gerald Ford kicked out Spiro Agnu they got rid of him Gerald
Ford who was also in the Warren Commission report that's right
they and then all of a sudden Nixon and Watergate happens Nixon
the most popular president of all time of all time and it turns
out that Bob Woodward was actually an intelligence agent and
this is his first project ever operation mockingber and then
the people that were involved in breakin all FBI is in real
Yeah. Okay.
And we're all schizophrenic. Are you there? Holy. Just press
the button. You got one job.